the polynomial expression 36 Y to the
third minus 100 y can be factored as 4y
times all of this my plus G times my
minus G or M and G are integers Sally
wrote the G could be equal to 3
Brandon rode the G could be equal to 10
which student is correct now when you
look at this it seems really daunting
all this M's and G's here but we just
need to realize that they're factoring
out first they factor out a 4y from the
36 Y to the 3rd minus 100 y and it looks
like whatever's left is a difference of
squares which they then factor even
further so I encourage you to pause the
video and just factor this out as much
as you can first factoring out a 4y and
then we could think about what G is
going to be equal to or whether Sally or
Brandon is correct
so now let's work through this let's
work through this together so if we look
at if we look at this expression right
over here and we want to factor out a 4
y so 36 Y to the third minus 100 Y
that's the same thing as 36 Y to the
third is the same thing as 4y times
let's see 4y times 9y squared right
because 4 times 9 is 36 and y times y
squared is y to the third so all I did
to get the 9y squared is that divided 36
by 4 to get the 9 and I divided Y to the
3rd by the Y to get Y squared so if you
factor out a 4 Y you're left with 9y
squared for that first term and then for
this second term let's see if we we're
going to subtract we factor out a 4 y
again we factor out a 4 y what's left
over 100 divided by 4 is 25 25 and then
Y and then Y divided by y is just 1 so
we're just left with a 25-year so just
to be clear what's going on this 36 Y to
the 3rd I just rewrote it as 4y times 9y
squared one way to think about it is I
wrote it with the 4y factor
and then the 100y right over here I
wrote it with the 4y factored out so
it's 4y times 25 and now it's very clear
that we can factor out 4y from this
entire thing so we can factor out you
could think of it as undistributing the
4y
so this is going to be equal to this is
going to be equal to 4y and what is left
over well if you factor out a 4y of this
first term we're going to have a 9y
squared 9y squared and then minus 25 and
then we're going to be left with minus
25 and when we write it like this we see
what we have in parentheses here this is
a difference of squares and we could
skip a step but let me just rewrite it
so we could rewrite it as literally a
difference of squares 9y squared that is
the same thing as that is the same thing
as 3y that whole thing to the second
power 3 squared is 9 Y squared is y
squared and then we have and then we
have minus 25 we can rewrite as 5
squared so you see we have a difference
of squares and we've seen this pattern
multiple times if this is the first time
you're seeing and I encourage you to
watch the videos on Khan Academy on
difference of squares but we know
anything of the form anything of the
form a squared minus B squared minus
minus B squared let me do it in that
color minus B squared can be factored as
being equal to this is equal to if I
were to write it as a product of binome
of two binomials this is going to be
equal to a a plus B a plus B times a
minus B times a minus B and you can
verify that that works if you've never
seen this before or you can watch those
videos for review so this right over
here can be re-written as for Y which we
factored out at the beginning it's going
to be times the product of two binomials
for this part right over here
and so in this case a is 3y so it's
going to be 3 y plus 5 times 3y minus 5
so let me write that down so 3y plus 5
plus 5 times 3y minus 5
3y minus 5
3y minus 5 so now that we factor this
let's let's go back to what what they
originally told us so that we have for y
so this 4y corresponds to that 4y right
over there and then you have my plus G
and then you have my minus G so you
could view the my the my is right over
there
that's the 3y right over there so we
could say that M is equal to 3 M is
equal to 3 and then we do plus 5 and
minus 5 plus G and minus G so G G if
we're pattern matching right over here G
is going to be equal to 5 so G is equal
to 5 so it's interesting about this
problem is that neither one of them
neither one of them are correct so I
could write neither is correct G is
equal to G is equal to 5 that was a
tricky one